Recuerdo que cuando estaba en la escuela aprendí
los números como 1, 2, 3, etcétera, pero
cuando vi el pizarrón de los cursos escolares
decía Curso I, es decir, Curso uno, y luego
el curso dos no estaba escrito como 2 sino
con dos íes, el curso tres estaba escrito
así, el curso cuatro estaba escrito como
una I y una V, y no entendí lo que estaba
pasando, así que le pregunté a mi maestra
qué era eso, ¿por qué no estábamos escribiendo
el término curso dos con el dos? Y ella dijo
que yo estaba acostumbrada a los números
indoarábigos, los que usamos generalmente,
pero hay otros tipos de números llamados
números romanos. Tuve mucha curiosidad y
también un poco de confusión, me preguntaba
por qué hay más de una forma de escribir
números y si estos son números romanos por
qué ya no los usamos. Y por supuesto me preguntaba
qué son los números romanos y por qué incluso
debería aprenderlos. Esa era la pregunta
principal: ¿por qué debería aprender otra
forma más de escribir números cuando ya
sabía una? Y cuanto más aprendía me daba
cuenta de que aprender sobre números romanos
era algo así como visitar un museo de matemáticas.
Si has ido a un museo normal, es posible que
hayas visto dinosaurios o sus esqueletos o
también algunos fósiles, y esto muestra
que el mundo no siempre ha sido como lo es
hoy, teníamos otras formas de hacer las cosas
que ya no usamos. Me di cuenta de que los
números romanos, o aprender números romanos,
es algo similar. Podemos retroceder en el
tiempo y ver cómo solíamos contar e incluso
pensar en preguntas como: ¿por qué ya no
contamos así?, y ¿si ahora lo estamos haciendo
mejor y por qué? De modo que aprendí más
sobre los números romanos. Tenía estas letras
que denotan algunos números, y al igual que
mis números habituales, tengo 1, 2, 3, 4
-cuando digo números habituales me refiero
a los números indoarábigos-, tengo 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, estos son mis dígitos,
y usando estos dígitos puedo formar cualquier
otro número. Estos son los dígitos del sistema
indoarábigo. Por supuesto también incluyo
el cero, que es bastante importante. Así
que los números indoarábigos van del 0 al
9. Del mismo modo, en el sistema romano tenían:
I, V, X, L C, D, M. Ahora bien, estas no son
las letras que realmente usaron, elegimos
las letras más cercanas a los símbolos que
se usaban; se usaba un símbolo que se parecía
a esto, básicamente como un palo, sólo un
palo vertical para denotar 1, y luego tenían
un símbolo V para 5, X para 10, L para 50
y C para 100. Probablemente es suficiente
que conozcas estos. Si estás interesado,
entonces tenemos D, y este L, C, D siempre
me llama la atención: D es para 500 y M es
para 1000. Saber esto no nos dice aún cómo
formar los números romanos, cómo leerlos
o escribirlos, todo lo que sabemos es que
son los dígitos que usan. Así que en el
sistema indoarábigo -tal vez debería escribir
sistema indoarábigo-, ¿cómo escribimos
números usando estos? Si quiero escribir
120, entonces tomaría una centena en mi tercer
dígito, luego pondría dos decenas y cero
unidades, a esto lo llamaría ciento veinte.
De modo que estoy usando el sistema de valor
posicional con el que probablemente estés
familiarizado en este momento. El sistema
de valor posicional. Los números romanos
no tenían un sistema de valor posicional,
ni siquiera tenían una letra específica
para 0, de modo que no hay 0 como puedes ver
aquí, son bastante diferentes de nuestros
números indoarábigos. Pero lo interesante
aquí es cómo leerlos y escribirlos, en realidad
no es recordar cómo hacerlo, probablemente
no lo hagas con mucha frecuencia, es sólo
un ejercicio divertido que vamos a hacer para
nuestros cerebros.